hi my name is Nick and I'm studying
physics for GCSE and I was just
wondering how large would we be if we
were made up of just our nuclei and not
the rest of our earth so Luke wants to
know how large would we be if we were
made up of our atomic nuclei without the
need for space for a whole atoms well
Adam is about a hundred thousand times
larger than an atomic nuclei so that
means if you take my size I'm about two
meters tall and / a hundred thousand
then I would be about 20 micrometers
tall if I were just made out of atomic
nuclei touching each other so how big is
20 micrometers it's about the thickness
of a human hair so just imagine me
sticking my arms out in a circle like
Leonardo da Vinci's man and draw a
circle around that that's about the size
of a human hair so it's a lot smaller